well you can get that DNA sequence DNA  sequencing a completely generic method  you can use it for soil use for plants  you could use a people saliva blood  tissue you use it for forensics you use  it for some ancient DNA and it's a it's  it's it's it's one of these generic it's  like tools it's kind of like the  computer you Peter for thousands of  different uses but your method was mine  was for all of those no I'm they have  been basic methods that you can use for  all these rooms and then in some cases  my lab was the first to apply it to some  of these things but the core technology  could be applied to more things than any  one lab you do you're up to some pretty  cool stuff